lo que espero hacer en este vídeo es
partir de esta gráfica de la función de
igual a fx y pensar en los intervalos
donde la función es positiva o es
negativa y luego pensar en los
intervalos donde la función crece o
decrece muy bien así que el primer paso
será analizar los intervalos donde la
función f x es positiva y cuando
pensamos en la función digamos en los
puntos donde la función es positiva son
aquellos donde la función es
estrictamente mayor que 0 verdad y en la
imagen o en la gráfica de la función se
ven justamente los puntos donde la
gráfica está arriba del eje x verdad
justamente donde está arriba del eje x
entonces si nosotros nos ponemos ver
esto nos ponemos a ver esta gráfica
vemos que justamente todos estos todos
estos son puntos donde la gráfica está
por arriba del eje x
aquí todos estos todos estos están por
arriba del eje x pero también tenemos
esto es verdad justamente estos que
tenemos de este otro lado están arriba
del eje x así que si quisiéramos
escribirlo un poco más matemático bueno
por ejemplo si esté fuera del punto y si
éste fuera el punto b y éste fuera el
punto c entonces aquellos puntos tales
que la función toma valores positivos
son aquellos que están entre a y b
verdad entonces x tendría que ser mayor
que a y menor que b y hay que notar que
estamos quitando el caso donde es igual
a verdad porque justamente la función en
a toma el valor cero y nosotros queremos
que sea estrictamente mayor que cero es
decir que sea positiva entonces este
primer intervalo es válido y el
siguiente puede ser también cuando x es
más grande que el valor de verdad y otra
vez no puede ser igual a c porque
justamente en se tome el valor cero y no
es positiva y queremos que sea
estrictamente positiva así que esta es
la forma digamos más matemática de
escribir que la función toma valores
positivos en esos intervalos vamos a ver
qué pasa ahora lo vamos a analizar
cuando la función toma valores negativos
cuando la función es negativa muy bien y
eso es justamente cuando digamos en la
gráfica observamos que está por debajo
del eje x por debajo del eje x tenemos
estos dos digamos estas dos porciones de
la gráfica ok ahí lo tenemos en estas
dos porciones de la gráfica tenemos que
la función es negativa es decir toma
valores menores que 0 así que esto es
cuando x es menor que a otra vez no
incluimos a porque nada vale cero o bien
puede ser los valores
tal que están entre b y c que son todos
los x mayores que b y menores que se muy
bien esto fue bastante fácil ahora vamos
a hacer algo más interesante vamos a
analizar los puntos en donde la función
es creciente o decreciente y una forma
de pensar cuando la función es creciente
por ejemplo es siempre que aumentamos x
jett debe aumentar o bien otra forma de
pensarlo es que la tasa de cambio de jr
respecto de x debe ser positiva así que
por ejemplo si pensamos a lo mejor bueno
esta es una forma de pensarlo no es la
única pues si pensamos en la
digamos recta tangente qué pasa por
algún punto de la gráfica vamos
no sé por ejemplo aquí en la recta
tangente su pendiente debe ser positiva
muy bien entonces podemos observar otra
forma de pensarlo quizás más fácil es
que si aumentamos x entonces que también
debe aumentar y viendo esto podemos ver
que por ejemplo en esta parte si
aumentamos xy aumenta y aumenta hasta
llegar hasta este punto verdad estamos
aumentando el valor de llega hasta
llegar a este punto muy bien también por
ejemplo ocurre que la función es
creciente a partir de este digamos de
este valle en adelante verdad a medida
que aumentamos x la el valor de y
también aumenta muy bien entonces vamos
vamos a caracterizar estos puntos
digamos vamos a ponerles nombre digamos
que este es el punto d
digamos que este es el punto
es el punto entonces la función
efe de x es creciente fx es creciente
justamente en estos intervalos verdad
todos aquellos puntos más pequeños que d
son todos aquellos puntos más pequeños
que veo de hecho de forma si lo decimos
más formal es todos aquellos x menores
que d y ojo tiene que ser menor estricto
que d
porque aquí digamos en este en este tope
digamos de esta desde de esta montaña ya
no crece verdad en este preciso punto ya
deja de crecer no crece ni decrece justo
en ese punto así que tienen que ser
todos aquellos puntos menores que de o
bien también pueden ser todos aquellos
puntos más grandes que son todos los x
mayores estrictos que
y de forma similar podemos pensar en los
puntos donde la función es decreciente
cuando la función f x es decreciente
pues sería justamente donde cada vez que
aumentamos x disminuimos y son todos
estos puntos
son todos estos puntos todos estos
puntos que van desde desde de hasta es
verdad lo podemos ver fácilmente cada
vez que aumentemos x disminuye y
aumentamos x disminuye y aumentamos x y
disminuye y así sucesivamente hasta
llegar a él otra vez no lo incluimos
porque aquí no decrece ni creces
simplemente digamos como que está
estacionado en ese punto muy bien
entonces fx es decreciente para todos
los equis que sean más grandes o más
mayores que de iu menores que el muy
bien y eso lo pudimos ver gráficamente
así que espero que tengas ahora una
mejor idea de estos dos conceptos y algo
que hay que notar es que los intervalos
donde la función es positiva o negativa
o donde decreciente y decreciente pueden
trasladarse de hecho son conceptos que
no tienen relación y hay que pensarlos
de forma separada aunque
suenen parecidos